Brenda's with us in Las Vegas hey Brenda
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey hey
what's up well my husband and I have
been we started saving for our
children's college education and with
our oldest starting college and just a
little over two years I just feel like
we are way behind and I would love some
advice on what I need to do what we need
to do to properly save for our
children's college education
what's your household income my
husband's a pastor so our actual take
home page is kind of a little bit
different but monthly when we bring home
around $5,000 a month okay and you have
two kids you have kids at what ages two
kids 16 and 14 okay and how much do you
have saved now in the education savings
we have about fifty eight hundred
dollars in our general savings I have a
little over five thousand dollars okay
and then we have kind of vacations and
savings which right now about three
hundred okay well basically what we're
saying is is in two years you're gonna
have probably not even half of what you
need probably not even afraid probably
not even 1/4 of what you need and so
there's a couple things you need to do
if a kid wants to go to school debt-free
and doesn't have any money or has
limited money and that's we're kind of
between no money and limited money in
this discussion so the first thing is
that you need to really get a realistic
grip on the number one cause of student
loan debt is college choice people
choose a freakin college that broke
people don't need to go to yes you have
a college in mind already so I don't
hear at college yeah I care they don't
get to make the decision right they're
teenagers they need help and they need
those things
parents because you know if you
participate in the decision for them to
go to a $45,000 your school you are
pretty much ensuring your child is going
to hate you when they're 30 because
they're going to be looking down the
nose of about a hundred thousand dollars
in student loan debt right and we want
to avoid that so where you go to school
matters and so basically these kids are
going to in-state state schools and or
community colleges for the first two
years to get their basics out of the way
for it a little to no money at the
Community College and then finish up at
an in-state state school here's the
interesting thing there's almost no jobs
and almost no degree fields that care
where you went to school I have never
gone to a doctor and went oh I can't let
you look at me because you went to the
wrong school I have never hired an
attorney this I said well we can't get
you to work on us because you didn't go
to George Washington you know I have
never never one time have I hired
somebody in this organization based on
where they went to school or didn't
happen so that garbage is out there
floating around but in the real world it
doesn't exist okay nobody asks nobody
has ever denied your husband a position
as a pastor based on where he went to
seminary unless it was a doctrinal issue
indicated by where he went to seminary
but not based on the quality of
education okay
yeah and so you know that's not that's
just not the case
so there's this garbage if you have to
go to some big-name school or those of
us that are Christians sometimes my
fellow Christians want to send their kid
only to a Christian college because it's
like they're going to go to hell if they
don't and maybe they could be salt and
light in the communion in the community
college maybe they could be salt and
light in the public college because
these kids ain't got the money for
Christian school I can't write you can't
forget you can't afford lesson let's get
hard percent free ride so number one is
college choice number two is they are
going to be working while they're in
school and before they get to school did
you go to college I did did you work
while you're in college
I did yeah me too and I came out of
college 100% debt-free though I had no
student loans me too well no I had
$3,000 I'll take that back in student
loans but that was before I was Dave
Ramsey so I had hair then so anyway the
so they're going to be working number
two number three their job right now
starting now is to take start taking the
AC T and take it again and take it again
most schools are now super scoring the
AC T which means they take you the best
of if you take it three times they take
the best science score you got of the
three they take the best math score of
the three they take the mat best English
score of the three and they put them
together and that's called a super score
and that becomes your AC T score and
then every time you take it you take
mentoring and tutoring in between that's
a good thing to spend money on on how to
take the tests so that you next time you
take it your score goes up all three of
my kids took the test more than twice
okay right make it more than actually I
took it twice yeah and and and every
time their scores went up by the way
because we did just exactly what
struggle met and then that leads us into
number four which is scholarships they
are now in the I won a scholarship
business and and it can be based on
their Christian faith and their mission
work that they've done and the
citizenship that that represents into
the citizens of the world or citizens of
the culture or whatever it can be based
on academics it can be based on but it's
usually just based on somebody's giving
away a scholarship and the kid that has
the best essay the turns it in gets it
and there's millions and millions and
millions of dollars that go unclaimed
every year on scholarships and so you go
to something like my scollay comm or
some of these other services that are
online and your child needs to fill out
1,000 scholarship applications between
now and the time they go to school
literally okay
literally not 100 because they're gonna
get turned down from 900 on them or
maybe not under 50 of them but if they
get fifty scholarships an average of
thousand dollars a piece they just went
to school great part-time job for a
teenager so scholarships work a CT and
overall college choice
you do all of those things you can get
through school now because if you start
looking at an in-state tuition versus a
private education that you can't afford
you're gonna see it's 5x college
education is going to be 5x call you
know and what happens though is is that
people let their teenagers make these
decisions in a vacuum based on the town
is pretty and so I want to go to school
there or based on I've always thought I
wanted to be a PhD in German polka
history I want to study something that
has absolutely no applicable use in the
marketplace and so your job is mom your
job as dad is to parent these kids and
they are kids I know they look like
they're grown up and all that kind of
stuff but they're not because every one
of us that have been 18 years old or
shaking our heads going we were stupid
and we needed parents that's how people
get a hundred and fifty thousand dollars
in debt because their parents aren't
involved and they make stupid decisions
about education isn't that oxymoronic
that we make stupid decisions about
education think about how dumb that'll
phrase I just said is this is the Dave
Ramsey show
[Music]